uh when I arrived I noticed there was
some smoke coming out of the vehicle as
I approached the vehicle I noticed
somebody had busted the window out of
the passenger side of the vehicle that
was there
um I tried to make entry through the
passenger door we finally did get the
door open but the gentleman that was in
the vehicle was leaning all the way over
to the driver's side of the vehicle so
we were unable to pull him out from the
passenger side I continued to drag him
back away from the car as I did that it
began more Flames more smoke coming out
of the vehicle before it became engulfed
in flames
as I did get closer I did notice that
Samaritan had already thrown something
into the window before I'd gotten up
there by the time I had gotten to the
passenger side I just asked everybody to
move back because the car had already
starting having smoke come out of it so
I was just trying to make the scene safe
while I was trying to work on getting
the driver out of the vehicle like I
said there was another Samaritan that
decided to stay which opened the
passenger door after the window was
busted trying to get the doors unlocked
you know what I think I think it was
awesome that he stayed I pushed a lot of
them back just to make sure the scene
was safe I mean that's what we are
taught to do is make sure the scene is
safe so nobody else gets injured and he
decided to stay and honestly through all
the adrenaline and trying to get the guy
out of the car I didn't notice he was
even there except for an arm being
pulled out and then him kind of helping
me pull this guy out if if we weren't
there I think he would have been burned
in the vehicle would he have died I
don't know but I think he would have
suffered severe burns just from how fast
the vehicle caught fire